bears
beats
battlestar galactica do you see him
do you think a depressed person could
make this
no no i'm fine it's just that life is
pointless and nothing matters and i'm
always tired also i can't sleep i'm
overeating none of my old hobbies
interest me
i have done nothing wrong
ever
in my life
i know this
and i love you oh
it's a white flag and you may as well
start waving it right now
i will be waving is your decapitated
head on a stick in front of your weeping
mother
good lord
anyways i'm gonna go cry in the bathroom
peace out homies
this is the worst
no question about it i am ready to get
hurt again
ed truck was a manager before me
horrible he hated fun it was like oh ed
truck is walking toward us
why are you the way that you are
honestly every time i try to do
something fun or exciting
you make it not that way
i hate
so much about the things that you choose
to be
this is my friend madison she's amazing
and she drove me here
it's beautiful
i've looked at this for five hours now
hi
i just wanted you to know we're about to
be arrested ah
look who hasn't had gay thoughts
what i love garbage dogging is the worst
chris
i mean i know it keeps you healthy but
god at what cost stay back [ __ ] someone
will die of fun
because we're smart
[Music]
i love inside jokes
i'd love to be a part of one someday
and you can knock it out [ __ ]
identity theft is not a joke jim
millions of families suffer every year
not to worry i have a permit
this just says i can do what i want
oh i have a medical condition all right
it's called caring too much
and it's incurable
why is no one having a good time i
specifically requested it
[Music]
i'm right behind you come on
yeah
parkour
what that is totally crazy i am super
chill all the time
i'm dead oh lord
is he eating soup on a bench alone i saw
the guy fake peeking knees
towards the cat
corporate needs you to find the
differences between this picture
and this picture
indel has told us there are at least
seven
okay i already see one given
okay
they're the same picture
i have total faith in you there's like a
30 chance they'll both die
if i keep my body moving and my mind
occupied at all times i will avoid
falling into a bottomless pit of despair
it's about the cones thank you let's
just go home yeah let's go
home no just go home no
no well remember when you told me not to
burn down the precinct you burned down
the precinct no i had the fire put out
almost immediately this is a success
story your department's just you right
yes jim but i am not easy to manage
jan is about to have a baby with a sperm
donor and michael is preparing for the
birth of a watermelon with dwight
now this baby will be related to michael
through
delusion
everything hurts and i'm dying
[Applause]
[Applause]
stop
pooping
i know more than you
all right
somebody follow me i'm distraught the
calzones
betrayed
me hey no no no no no no no no no no no
no no no no no no no no no no no
pain
as i was saying right now we are talking
louder okay our prices have never been
low you have to talk louder never been
lower louder son but liquor our prices
have never been lower
no
god
no god please no no
no
no
oh my god okay it's happening everybody
stay calm
everyone what's the procedure
okay
good morning then oh i love nothing
this place is outstanding oh so just
because i can't go out with him someone
else can oh boy wow okay
thank you alcohol
[Applause]
ah two three four
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
it's britney [ __ ]
everybody is going to get to know each
other in the pot
i'm serious about this stuff
i'm up the night before pressing garlic
and dicing whole tomatoes i toast my own
ancho chilies
it's a recipe passed down from malone's
for generations
it's probably the thing i do best
i am 100 certain that i am zero percent
sure of what i'm going to do i'm never
gonna be a cop
i'm gonna have to be a robber i'm i'm
not crying okay i'm allergic to jerks my
anxiety has kept me up for over 50 hours
boom
sadness that's the one
leslie are you okay
[Music]
you